mais d'abord donc on décortique la carte
électorale de cette présidentielle 2022
on commence par le vote le pen comment
ces électeurs vive t-il la défaite
samedi à de chirée gaspard flamands se
sont rendus à bruay la buissière ville
du pas de calais qui a voté à rennes à
69% dimanche en
de tous les bureaux de vote de bruay la
buissière c'est ici qu'elle a fait le
meilleur score plus de 84% des électeurs
y ont donné leur voix à marine le pen au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
l'école jean jaurès est au coeur du
nouveau monde un quartier de corons l'un
des plus populaires de cette ville du
pas de calais je suis très déçu parce
que personnellement j'ai voté marine le
pen
je pense qu'elle propose mieux que
emmanuel macron bas je ressens de la
tristesse de la colère parce que les
gens et se plaignent au final bah c'est
tout le temps le même résultat à quoi tu
très très très déçu
parce que il fait rien pour nous
les retraités on les met sur le côté il
fait plus pour pour les riches on
voulait que ce soit marine qui passe
bon voilà maintenant c'est comme ça
c'est tout c'est reparti pour cinq ans
en 2020 cette ancienne cité minière
s'est choisi un maire étiqueté
rassemblement national tous racontent
des fins de mois difficiles qui motive
leur vote marine le pen et chacun a sa
propre explication sur la défaite de
dimanche je pense que les gens les gens
ont un peu peur les gens ont cette
gérer cette vision un peu
du pape a enfin dû jean marie qui était
un peu trop
un peu trop radical je pense surtout que
les médias étaient du côté de monsieur
macron bien évidemment à sa salle a
fortement aidé on n'a pas vu une
campagne électorale non plus très
développée avec des moyens mis en oeuvre
comme certains ont pu le faire
malheureusement elle a perdu je pense
que ça se jouera toujours à peu de
choses il ya le barrage contre elle et
beaucoup de politiques se chargent dire
qu'elle fait peur et apparemment ça
marche de temps en temps et après bon il
ya tous les gens qui ne votent pas ou
qui votent blanc et puis j'aurais dû
voter pour la sortie de ce centre
commercial plus proche du centre ville
les électeurs de marine le pen sont un
peu moins nombreux mais restent
majoritaires tous attendent des manuels
macron qu'il entende les mécontents ceux
qui ont voté pour marine le pen comme
ceux qui ont fait barrage à l'extrême
droite sans pour autant adhérer au
projet macro nist j'attends qu'ils nous
aient quotas j'attends qu'ils nous
écoutent
surtout sur la retraite le pouvoir
d'achat
j'espère qu'il va essayer de réconcilier
les français même que les français se
réconcilient de même on espère nous ici
dans nord et le pas de calais que il va
il voit qu'il ya quand même 45 % de
mécontents
et que surtout pouvoir d'achat l'état
action avec 69% des voix sur l'ensemble
de la ville
marine le pen a gagné plus de 10 points
depuis la dernière élection
présidentielle à bruay la buissière
et comme promis on analyse en détail
cette carte électorale avec mes invités
adélaïde zulfikarpasic bonjour bienvenue
vous êtes directrice du département
opinion chez eux bba france enseignante
à sciences po et vous publiez avec anne
muxel les français sur le fil de
l'engagement c'est aux éditions de
l'aube hervé lebras bonsoir bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous aussi démographe
historien directeur d'études à l'école
des hautes études en sciences sociales
auteur de il n'y a pas de grand
remplacement publié aux éditions grasset
richard verdi bonsoir soir est
correspondant quotidien suisse le temps
auteur de la france contre elle-même de
la démarcation de 1940 aux fractures
d'aujourd'hui c'est publié également
chez grasset et bienvenue à laetitia
club avançant laetitia éditorialiste
politique donc on commence par le vote
le pen adélaïde zulfikarpasic c'est un
vote d'adhésion et où un vote de rejet
du président macron il ya un peu des
deux c'est ça il ya ka mandé de et à
parts égales puisque c'est la différence
d'ailleurs une des différences
principales avec manuel mâcon qu'il faut
souligner il a été assez peu élus pour
ces propositions alors que le vote pour
marine le pen quand on demande à ses
électeurs pour quelles raisons ils ont
voté pour elle il cite en première
raison son programme ses propositions il
ya clairement un vote d'adhésion 51%
mais dans la même dans le même temps 50%
de son électorat déclare avoir voté pour
elle pour faire barrage à emmanuel
macron donc un vote d'adhésion un vote
de barrage là où le vote en faveur de m
d'abord un vote de barrage face à marine
le pen est aussi un vote de réassurance
continuité parce qu'on choisit aussi
pour sa stature présidentielle mais
effectivement un vote d'adhésion teintée
de colère contre le président de la
république mais alors si on rentre un
petit peu plus dans le détail je le
disais dans dans les titres et c'est
d'ailleurs c'est le résultat d'un
sondage que vous avez réalisé pour pour
ouest france on voit que 71% des classes
défavorisées ont choisi marine le pen
75% des classes aisées et supérieurs ont
choisi emmanuel macron hervé le bras est
ce que moi je dis c'est un vote en
miroir peut-être que c'est pas la
meilleure expression comment vous
définissez ça
je pense que c'est quand même on l'a
beaucoup dit c'est un vote de 2,2 france
et en même temps on pourrait presque
dire de 2,4 france parce qu'il ya deux
france en termes de région c'est à dire
qu'il ya des régions qui depuis le début
vote pour le fn puis pour le rnc une
grande bande nord-est disons tout ce qui
est au nord de havre belfort tout les
rivages méditerranéens puis la moyenne
vallée de la garonne lot et garonne et
tarn et garonne là c'est un vote qui et
reste depuis maintenant 1984 fixés sur
ces régions et c'est un vote de région
qui dans l'ensemble sont plus pauvres
ont un chômage plus élevé on déjeune
moins éduquées donc il dit social
derrière et puis là l'autre au fond
grandes
disparités et qui s'est renforcé dans
ces élections c'est entre les campagnes
entre les zones rurales et les grandes
villes à l'exécration absolument énorme
pour les communes qui font 10 ont moins
de 3000 habitants c'est un peu près 30%
au premier tour de vote pour marine le
pen pour celles qui font plus de 100000
habitants c'est 12% et pour paris c'est
5,5
des failles dont 505 elle même et ça se
renforce avec plus en plus donc il ya
sept ses deux sauts font ces deux
oppositions l'opposition rural grandes
villes et puis l'opposition une france
qui va mal et une france qui va bien
plutôt bien socialement alors et si on
revient sur le premier tour est ce que
font la salle richart wehrli on
retrouvait trois blocs politiques au
premier tour c'est compliqué on a 4
france ô miroir trois votes trois blocs
au premier tour bref ça donne la
complexité à la fois de de l'analyse et
puis peut-être aussi des projections des
des instituts de sondages ou des
politiques pour législatif ça on y
reviendra est ce que ça donne forcément
vous qui avez
était touchée ça sur le terrain d'une
certaine façon pour votre livre des
français irréconciliables moi je ne
crois pas je crois que les francs la
france qui votent marine le pen dans les
zones géographiques que viennent
d'écrire monsieur le bras c'est une
france qui est en attente et si elle
continue de voter marine le pen est
d'ailleurs les témoignages que vous en
tant que vous avez montré le voyez c'est
parce qu'ils n'ont pas obtenu
satisfaction ou qu'ils n'ont pas eu
l'impression que ces cinq dernières
années il suffisamment de message
suffisamment de mesures leur étaient
adressées et moi qui me suis intéressé
dans le livre donc au tour de la ligne
de démarcation vous savez qui en 1940
traverser la france en deux dans des
zones essentiellement rurale de l'az en
gros de la touraine au jura avec ensuite
cette descente à le parallèle au
littoral atlantique qu'est ce que vous
voyez vous voyez effectivement une
population qui doute mais qui n'est pas
foncièrement hostiles à emmanuel macron
et moi je crois que j'ai un petit peu de
peine à penser que les 40% qui ont voté
marine le pen sont foncièrement hostiles
à même le lac rond je crois qu'une
partie d'entre eux auraient pu se poser
la question d'un autre vote que celui de
marine le pen
sauf que sauf que rien dans l'offre
politique n'a semblé leur convenir rien
n'a semblé s'intéresser à leurs
problèmes et je crois c'est cette
désaffection qui moi et pour moi le
problème le plus important parce que
tant que les le président renouveler son
gouvernement ne feront pas attention à
cette masse de population elle
continuera de voter parce que le
carburant social que vous citiez et bien
il est là il va continué de brûler ce
carburant sociale quant à elle mais doit
être dans les coulisses comme promis on
va regarder de plus près la la carte
électorale elle est là la chronique de
cancer bonsoir en sarthe vous avez
étudié à plusieurs échelons voilà tout à
fait on va commencer par la carte des
départements comme ça monsieur le bras
va tout de suite voir ce que vous
commenciez à évoquer déjà dans le
premier tour de table marine le pen est
arrivé en tête au second tour dans 21
départements de la métropole surtout
dans le nord dans l'est de la france et
le sud est on y ajoute les deux
départements de corse ainsi que de
nombreux territoires d'outre-mer la
guadeloupe la martinique et la guyane
saint-martin saint-barthélemy
saint-pierre-et-miquelon la réunion
mayotte emmanuel macron est majoritaire
dans les territoires de polynésie en
nouvelle calédonie wallis et futuna ce
qui est intéressant de noter c'est la
dynamique entre 2017 et 2022 car marine
le pen arrive en tête dans une vingtaine
de départements contre seulement deux en
2010 cette laine et le pas-de-calais ce
que l'on voit aussi dans cette carte
réalisée par nos confrères de la croix
c'est que les départements qui votent au
dessus de la moyenne nationale pr gnagne
macron sont surtout en bretagne et dans
l'ouest de la france alors ensuite vous
êtes allé à l'échelon communal voilà et
on voit et bien les mêmes géographie de
vote le nord et l'est de la france ainsi
que le sud-est vote pour marine le pen
sur 35 mille communes la candidate du
rassemblement national est arrivé en
tête dans dix-huit mille d'entre elles
s'est elle bien moitié moins que 2010
est alors mediapart a cherché les zones
de force de chaque vente et moitié moins
en 2010 oui pardon mais c'était motivant
était un homme ait laissé 2010
exactement mais que 2017 je me suis
trompé oui mais c'est pas grave
j'avais pris mediapart à chercher lé les
zones de force effectuant de chaque vote
et là on voit apparaître une nouvelle
donne et les villes et grandes villes
apparaissent nettement dans cette carte
emmanuel macron fait d'énormes score à
paris 1 85% dans les hauts-de-seine 80 %
ou encore à lyon également 80% ce qui
nous a poussés et bien effectivement
regarder les votes par catégorie
d'agglomération et la réfection on
retrouve le clivage qu'on commençait à
évoquer en plateau reggae ce diagramme
en fait et bien c'est très simple les
petites communes place à égalité quasi
parfaite
emmanuel macron et marine le pen et puis
plus la commune est grande et puis plus
le vote c'est du miel macron efforts
merci quant à pour pour ces détails
hervé le bras et le moi je retiens quand
même essayer de le chiffre sur lesquels
on a hésité elle elle arrive en tête
marine le pen dans dix-huit mille
communes
c'était effectivement
deux fois plus qu'en 2010 est là on est
dans un ancrage et vous parliez delà du
temps d'un ancrage qui commence à être
profond tant la wii mais ces dix-huit
mille communes qui sont essentiellement
des très bonnes mais nous savons que
vous l'avez forcément fin donc malgré
tout macron là assez largement emporté
en terme de population donc c'est
surtout c'est surtout cela qui compte
donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que ce
genre de carte communale est un tout
petit peu trompeuse parce qu'au fond
parie sur une carte comme ça en occupe
la même surface que une commune
des hautes-alpes qui a 300 habitants
bien sûr mais est ce que la france qui
votent macron et
peut-être que je vais un peu caricaturée
dans mes questions mais c'est celle qui
ne se sent pas ou en tout cas moins
largué par la mobilise la mondialisation
la transition numérique ou même la
transition écologique qu'est ce que vous
direz oui mais je pense qu'il ya un
ressort plus profond quand même au au
malaise s'est un peu cherché des
indicateurs qui justement oppose les
zones rurales aux zones plus urbaine et
aux grandes villes et je pense quand
même que c'est des questions d'ascension
sociale qui sont derrière quand par
exemple quand on on regarde
oui le potentiel c'est à dire au fond
quand on vote on vote pas simple pour
votre pour sa situation présente mais on
vote surtout par anticipation sur
l'avenir que on espère et dans les zones
qu'ils votent partiquement dans les
zones rurales de l'est et de la
méditerranée qui votent beaucoup pour le
front national il ya une certaine
désespérance on a l'impression que
l'avenir est bouché en termes de
d'ascension sociale et il faut se
souvenir que là c'est une différence
très ancienne parce que c'est des
régions où l'exode rural est très ancien
donc ben on a été dans les années trente
ouvriers puis peut-être un peu plus
employé puis ça stagne ya eu aussi la
désindustrialisation
quand vous êtes dans l'ouest et le
sud-ouest les zones rurales est beaucoup
plus tardif la gv et publié une carte
bien qu'ils montrent qu'ils
correspondaient très bien au vote macron
c'était de la carte de la proportion
d'agriculteurs en 1968 alors vous dites
mais ça n'a pas grand chose à voir si
parce que les enfants de ces
agriculteurs sont devenus en général
ouvriers et puis leurs petits enfants
sont maintenant plus de gens dans des
emplois à moyen ou même plus plus élevé
donc on voit que l'ascension de social a
fonctionné ya encore un souvenir vous
font même par exemple en bretagne dans
l'ouest de la misère qui régnait il ya
deux générations et ça c'est plus vrai
dans le dans laisse donc il ya quelque
part et au fond que j'étais d'accord
avec l'économiste daniel cohen qui avait
un peu tentés de ranger sa sous le terme
la france optimiste et la france
pessimiste ni optimiste ou pessimisme à
cause des possibilités d'ascension
sociale et dans cette france pessimistes
avec moins on va dire de le perspectives
d'ascension sociale il ya aussi celles
des quartiers populaires mais cette fois
ci les banlieues des grandes villes qui
a voté jean luc mélenchon massivement au
premier tour on est un peu dans le même
mode sauve qui n'est pas aller vers un
vote marine le pen quand même oui
effectivement on a vu ce que le holà on
l'a vu d'ailleurs sur la première
question qu'on a commenté sur le vote
marine le pen qui à la fois un vote
d'adhésion pour partie est un vote pour
faire barrage l'allemagne mâcon pour une
autre partie on voit qu'à des électeurs
de jean luc mélenchon qui ont fait le
choix au second tour de voter pour
certains une le pen ar ils sont 18% et
puis une partie ont choisi de s'abstenir
ou alors de soutenir quand même
massivement emmanuel macron moi
j'aimerais revenir à ce qu'on disait sur
ces deux france qu'on parle de france
pessimiste optimiste ou de france
irréconciliables jeu pas très favorable
en kiosque on a ce qu'on oppose de
france parce que ça vient attiser
peut-être quelque chose il est séparé
encore plus mais c'est vrai quand même
voix et c'est indéniable je ne sais pas
si elles sont irréconciliables on voit
des lignes de clivage très forte et qui
se retrouve aussi dans les thématiques
des préoccupations et motivation de vote
de chacune de ces de ces deux électorats
avec d'un côté un électorat d'emmanuel
macron qui placent sur
au premier rang de ses priorités les
questions en tout cas qui nous disent
que dans leur choix de vote dimanche à
la question européenne
alors on allait on allait on a les chars
on va les voir pendant que vous ne les
expliquer les i à la caisse l'europe a
beaucoup compté les questions
internationales la situation économique
de la france et de l'autre côté un
électorat de marine le pen qui a
positionné la question du pouvoir
d'achat les questions d'immigration
alors attendez vous allez trop vite là
on est sûr
c'est pas fou toujours facile à suivre
donc là on a vraiment les motivations du
vote des
relations internationales situation
économique de la france est en première
position et pouvoir d'achat seulement en
quatrième en quatrième position et si on
compare avec la carte avec les réponses
des électeurs de marine le pen
on voit que la priorité numéro un c'est
la question du pouvoir d'achat cité deux
fois plus que par les électeurs des
manuels macron devant les questions
d'immigration et de sécurité est-ce que
ce que ça veut dire en fait et ça
rejoint cette analyse entre france
optimiste et france ô pessimiste à
décines quand même un peu deux
électorats 1 j'ai envie de dire qu'il va
suffisamment bien pour s'ouvrir à
l'extérieur et se préoccuper c'est un
peu comme cette tension sur l'écologie
qu'on ressent entre fin du monde et fin
du mois une france qui est qu'ils
avaient envie de dire presque les moyens
la possibilité de s'interroger sur la
situation
l'ukrainienne sur la question les
questions internationales sur l'état de
la dette ou de notre balance commerciale
et une france qui
alors je pense que ce n'est pas qu'une
question de projection et d'anticipation
c'est une france qui comme au quotidien
rencontrent des difficultés et qui est
plus tourné vers elle parce qu'elle n'a
pas d'autre choix que de se voit là de
s'interroger sur comment je fais pour
payer mes trajets pour aller travailler
comme enjeu boucler mes fins de mois et
donc c'est à la fois effectivement la
question de l'ascension sociale et la
projection de la capacité à espérer un
avenir meilleur pour ses enfants mais
c'est aussi une france qui qui vient
qu'un quotidien beaucoup plus difficile
donc donc on voit comme d'être même si
on ne veut pas opposer de france parce
que moi je suis pas très favorable à ça
on voit quand même qu'on a des
sociologies électoral et des motivations
de vote qui sont extrêmement différentes
d'un électorale et alors oui je
m'interroge toujours sur notre obsession
à identifier à équipe tu es à mettre
dans des catégories me semble que c'est
pour nous rassurer parce que les deux
france dont on parle là depuis deux
semaines elle existe je rappelle
qu'avant il y avait un clivage droite
gauche et je pense que sociologiquement
géographiquement démographiquement on
pouvait aussi
identifié deux france qui s'opposait
simplement ce qui a changé thomas c'est
que pourquoi c'est un élément dit
peut-être ainsi si vous la prenez ou pas
mais je vous la met sur la table
pourquoi cette percée du rassemblement
national parce que le parti socialiste a
disparu et que la droite ait l'air a
disparu donc
ouvriers qui votaient oui mais vous
voyez bien qu'il y avait là pour 2022
emmanuel macron et face à lui marine le
pen donc c'est à dire que si on peut
voter alors bien sûr qu'ils avaient jean
luc mélenchon on est d'accord mais
jean-luc mélenchon représentant la
gauche on sait avec l'histoire des
gauches irréconciliables ce n'est pas
une évidence pour tout le monde donc il
y avait quand même une certaine
crispation peut-être vis-à-vis de cette
incarnation très particulière de
jean-luc mélenchon et donc quand on ne
veut voter contre emmanuel macron eh
bien on voit que marine le pen oui cela
explique pour aussi
et c'est pas justement parce que les
parties que vous évoquez le parti
socialiste ait l'air n'ont pas su
apporter de réponse à ces français en
souffrance de vote ouvrier ci s'est
déporté vers d'autres candidats que
initialement de parts sociales c'est
pour ça qu'ils disent ont disparu parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas su apporter les
bonnes réponses personnes qui ont ces
trophées charge n'oublions pas aussi
c'est vrai notamment pour la région on
aurait pu y aller je me réfère aux
reportages que vous diffusiez qu'il y à
un moment donné le vote le pen devient
quasiment le vote identitaire d'une d'un
département le wagon qui donc iter de
plusieurs localités au fond tout comme
ces localités il y a vingt ou trente ans
et là je parle sous le contrôle de
monsieur levrat voter communiste donc il
y à un espèce d'élan le pen on vote le
pen parce qu'elle est la candidate comme
ça qui peut quelquefois même on ne se
pose pas la question je me souviens être
allé à hénin beaumont il faut
reconnaître qu'à hénin beaumont ville
dirigée vous le savez par leur assemblée
nationale le vote le pen devient
quasiment le vote naturel c'est le vote
légitime donc peut-être n'allons pas
toujours voir dans ce vote l'expression
d'une absolue colère ou d'un absolu
rejet c'est simplement que les gens
s'identifient à cette candidate nommée
marine le pen parce qu elle leur parle
ça rejoint ce que vous 18h et c'est ce
que j'évoquais sur un ancrage durable en
fait dans weeds dans cette région est
aussi haut dans la partie sud-est oui
c'était élections oui mais qui sait
fabriquer assez lentement vous avez
il est très présent dans ces
eaux font très souvent on a dit
maintenant c'est les réseaux sociaux qui
fabrique le vote si c'était vrai il y
aurait pas de géographie parce que les
réseaux sociaux n'ont pas de géographie
qu'ils ont mais on est
exactement mais sinon mais en fait ce
qui se passe c'est que au fond on vote
en fonction des gens qui votent autour
de voilà donc le vote et le vote est un
un phénomène beaucoup plus dirait qu'une
anthropologique que sociologique sa
série guerre oui on peut dire grégaire
mais surtout c on vote en fonction de ce
que les personnes avec qui on discute au
bistrot avec le sur le lieu de travail
ont voté l'opinion se former vous avez
raison à partir du moment où il a une
certaine masse elle tend à se maintenir
mais ça a été vrai de tous les partis
politiques depuis la 3ème régiment
nouveau cfa nouveau et qui apparaît
vraiment de maintenant nettement c'est
le vote rural en faveur de marine le pen
ça c'est nouveau ça vanne existante
on peut le suivre dans votre carte il ya
département il se trouve que je le
connais bien c'est celui qui est le plus
au sud de cette bande de peines et la
nièvre la nièvre remplaçante de la
france la nièvre qui vote
majoritairement front national par
assemblée nationale laniel département
de françois mitterrand je vous le
rappelle la le masque le basculement il
est très symbolique et on peut dater un
il ay les îles d'acdn quand on prend le
vote le pen au tout début mais manquant
encore en 1995 ou 2002 il est également
répartie selon la taille des communes il
est aussi fort dans des villes que dans
les zones rurales et ça bascule avec
l'élection de sarkozy vous savez sarkozy
réalise que le pen a qualifié d'un
hold-up ya un tiers des voix classique
du fn qui vont vers sarkozy mais c'est
les voix des zones urbaines et à ce
moment là l'écart s'amplifie de plus en
plus et on arrive maintenant même entre
les deux tours le supplément de vote
pour marine le pen a été beaucoup plus
important dans les zones rurales que
dans les zones urbaines alors on va dans
le même esprit parce que là on parle des
optimistes ou des pessimistes mais on va
essayer de faire un parallèle avec le
vote gilet jaune maintenant et je vous
propose un premier chiffre concernant ce
vote sur les jaunes c'est celui de
l'abstention c'est intéressant parce que
elle est moins élevé 21 % d'abstention
là encore c'est ses bébés à qui nous
propose ce chiffre pour prouesse france
21% d'un stand d'abstention de parmi les
j ai je rappelle que c'est plus de 28%
au niveau au niveau national laetitia si
on rentre un peu dans le détail comment
ont-ils voté mais je vais m'appuyer sur
les étagères des sondages mais il est
apparu hier dans ouest france les gilet
jaune ont voté à 70 % pour marine le pen
mais plus que la couleur politique
thomas moi c'est l'aspect précurseur de
ce mouvement parce que il est souvent
affublés de qualificatifs négatifs et
bien moi je préfère du positif et les
gilets jaunes sont précurseurs pourquoi
parce que eux-mêmes ont choisi déjà de
dépasser le bipartisme c'est à dire que
les catégories dj les jo ne se sont
reconnus ni dans le parti socialiste ni
dans le parti de droite traditionnel et
des certains observateurs comme le
géographe christophe guilluy l'i10
depuis plusieurs années et coûter par
exemple ce qu'il disait sur france inter
en 2018 moi je décris une des catégories
qui sont potentiellement majoritaire
comme le rappelait un les classes
populaires en france d'ailleurs comme en
europe et aux états unis restent
majoritaires on les voit peu moins parce
qu'elles sont très éloignés mais elles
sont de fait majoritaire ces catégories
ont voté à droite ont voté à gauche
enfants tels extrêmement riche en
nouveautés à l'extrême gauche mais
surtout ce sont des catégories que ceux
qui se sont désaffiliés elles sont
désaffiliés non pas parce qu'elles ont
envie de se désaffilier mais parce que
l'offre politique ne correspond plus à
leur demande donc on voit bien quelque
chose qui est beaucoup plus large
beaucoup plus large que la question
politique en réalité ces catégories ont
déjà abandonné le clivage gauche droite
c'est difficile de définir ces
catégories c'est pour ça à mon avis
quand on garde le nom les gilet jaune au
pluriel parce que un gilet jaune on ne
sait pas comment
définir ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est que c'est la défiance vis-à-vis de
la politique et finalement la valeur la
plus commune à ces personnes qui se
disent et se revendique gilet jaune
j'imagine que c'est comme cela que vous
avez pu les comptabiliser c'est parce
que ces personnes venant se disent gilet
jaune donc il faudrait voir aussi au
premier tour peut-être la façon dont ils
ont voté et pour cerner ce phénomène un
gilet jaune je vais vous confier une
partie de la conversation que j'ai eue
hier avec jérôme sainte-marie qui est un
des ceux qui travaillent sur sur ce
sujet et qui me disait qu'il avait écrit
un livre qui est souvent cité sans citer
l'auteur c'est le livre bloc contre bloc
donc il avait été au rize et se fait
qu'un bloc élitaire qui vote manuel
macro s'opposer à un bloc populaire et
il me disait au temps le vote élitaire
et très facilement identifiables autant
le bloc populaire alors que lui
travaille depuis plusieurs années sur
cette thématique échappe encore à tout
une qualification est ce que vous êtes
d'accord est ce que ce bloc populaire
d'abord est-ce que vous reprenez la
définition et skins est indéfinissable
non peu comme tous les blogs c'est s et
des simplifications voulez vous l'avez
dit ce qui est plus difficile à définir
moi je crois c'est quand même cette
histoire de gilets jaunes parce que
rappelez vous ils sont présentés ils ont
présenté deux listes aux européennes en
1900 2015 2000 2010 9 elles ont fait
toutes les deux ensemble 0,7 pour cent
donc c'est assez compliqué les gilet
jaune et quand on cherche à savoir qui
gilet jaune à part ceux qui se disent
gilet jaune c'est pratiquement
impossible moi je les avais uniquement
repéré par il ya eu un sondage avant la
première grande manifestation la veille
qui ne s'était pas un sondage c'était
sur internet ceux qui n avaient déclaré
qu'ils participeraient sur un grand soin
à la manifestation du 17 novembre donc
ça faisait des les nombres importants et
là on pouvait le de le diviser par la
population des départements si vous
voulez et ça donnait ce qu'on a appelé
la diagonale du vide c'est à dire
c'était pas forcément la france la plus
pauvre justement c'était une autre
france c'était la france lointaine celle
qui est obligé c'était un peu la cause
première de prendre sa voiture pour
aller pour un grand nombre de spas
voulons de nécessité parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'autres n'y a pas d'autre choix et
ça correspondait très bien leur
implantation au fond les cartes que
publie l'insee sur la distance aux
prochains médecin la distance est un
ensemble de services donc c'est plutôt
sale j'irai d'essence des gilets jaunes
ensuite bien tout le monde c'est venu de
partout leur effectivement c'est
indéfinissable maintenant hagit léger
sur la question de
l'engagement de la défiance de ligne
politique quand même et ils ont plus
voté enfin ceux qui se définissent
encore une fois comme j'ai jaune dans
cette second tour de la présidentielle
ils ont plus voté que la moyenne
nationale est ce que le fait de se
définir comme j'ai jaune c'est une forme
d'engagement drôle comme cet engagement
dont vous parlez dans votre livre oui
c'est l'explication à laquelle je suis
arrivé parce que ça peut ça vous
surprendre parce qu'on peut se dire
c'est vrai que j'ai les jaunes ont lavé
on la veille quand on a un peu étudiés
on voit que c'est un mouvement qui est
très hétéroclite et qui regroupe
différents types de catégorie donc on
peut pas généraliser relais gilet jaune
en général mais au pluriel mais on
aurait pu effectivement y met enfin
supposer que en raison de leur profil un
peu sociologie cd plutôt des gens qui
avaient tendance à s'abstenir davantage
que la moyenne et là on voit dans l'
enquête qu'ils ont davantage voté alors
passer ceux qui se déclarent comme
ancêtre des gens qui ont un engagement
encore plus fort de lens voilà mais
effectivement c'est une forme
d'engagement qui fait que à la fois ils
ont sans doute voulu exprimer quelque
chose plus fortement que la moyenne
nationale est sans doute que ça on sait
très bien qu'en parce que c'était une
des grands un des grands sujets de notre
quinquennal qui se termine je pense que
dans le vote de colère et de
d'expression de barrage à emmanuel
macron
là c'était une occasion qu'il aurait été
donnée et sans doute que plus que par de
l'abstention ils ont voulu mettre ça
dans un vote
alors je voudrais qu'on se projette un
peu vers les législatives est d'abord
avec ce chiffre qu'il faut quand même
rappeler parce que on passe souvent
rapidement sur les chiffres de
l'abstention des mets en nombre en
millions de français 13 millions 600
mille absentionnistes dimanche 2 million
deux cent mille votes blancs 808 vote
nul ça donne un total de 16 millions 600
mille ha plus même de ses ennemis on s'y
ennuie français ont pas participé à
cette élection est cher wehrli l'enjeu
la des 50 jouent un peu moins qui nous
mène au premier tour de législatives ça
pourrait être pour tous les partis
d'ailleurs de les mobiliser de les
remobiliser ce que vous diriez mission
impossible en général on vote encore
moins au fond législatif coprésidents
c'est vrai que ça paraît extrêmement
difficile de les mobiliser pour les
législatives d'autant que le mode de
scrutin majoritaire
on le sait bien risque de conduire à une
disproportion à l'assemblée nationale
entre les formations qui ont des députés
et les formations qui sont populaires
dans le pays à quoi bon voter le vecteur
donne aussi une très grande prime aux
sortants on l'oubli il faut le rappeler
mais cette abstention je dois dire elle
me elle me chagrine mais elle ne me
choque pas tant que ça parce que d'abord
si vous regardez au niveau européen
toutes les démocraties européennes sont
confrontées je parlerai même pas des
états unis toutes les démocraties
européennes sont confrontés au même
phénomène c'est à dire qu'une partie de
la population a perdu confiance dans la
démocratie représentative
ou tout simplement estime que de toute
manière sa voix ne changera rien et donc
elle ne va voter donkey ce qu'il y a là
un mal français particulier jeu
malheureusement je crois pas et une
deuxième chose c'est que il y a il faut
le reconnaître surtout dans les jeunes
générations des nouvelles habitudes
peut-être que le vote tel qu'il est par
exemple je vais prendre un exemple en
suisse le vote par correspondance existe
je ne dis pas qu'il faut le faire en
france mais ça permet à beaucoup de gens
de voter il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
envie de tempêtes de fer procuration qui
pourraient voter par correspondance donc
il ya peut-être aussi des nouvelles
méthodes de vote qu'il faudrait accepter
de prendre en compte je n'ai pas si
elles sont sécurisés haute mais
peut-être que ça aiderait aussi un
certain nombre de citoyens à retourner
aux yeux même si c'est pas une urne avec
un isoloir rideau con qu'on ferme etc
voilà ça fait partie des chantiers
évidemment de ce second chantier
démocrate j'ai même eu un chantier
démocratique est évident alors je vous
propose un premier sondage de projection
vers les législatives c'est l'institut
harris interactive qui le propose pour
nos confrères de challenges évidemment à
prendre avec beaucoup de prudence les
lys elles sont même pas encore déposé
bref scénario premier scénario alors là
vous le voyez il est sans alliance avant
législatives on voit une majorité
absolue pour la république en marche le
rassemblement national entre 75 et 105
sièges la france insoumise entre 25 et
45 elle est entre 35 et 65 le parti
socialiste entre 20 et 40 le second
scénario là on imagine des alliances
avant les législatives avant le vote
trois grandes forces c'est ça simplifie
toi lrm et ses alliés modem horizons et
l'est on intègre elle est rude et y là
on a aussi une majorité absolue ensuite
il ya le rassemblement national qui se
seraient alliés c'est très hypothétique
1 avec reconquête
ou debout la france et
donc là on est bien au-delà on et 117 à
147 sièges et puis ensuite il ya une
alliance une grande alliance de gauche
l'union populaire rêvé par jean luc
mélenchon avec le pc le ps europe
ecologie les verts où on flirte avec les
80 et 100 sièges dans le meilleur des
cas entre 73 et 93 sièges petite
question alors c'est pas votre institut
adélaïde mais
c'est difficile
ça peut être quoi la méthode pour donner
des fourchettes comme celle là peut-être
que vous avez vous commencé à délaisser
conflit en tout cas ils ont pas vu faire
une enquête circonscription par
circonscription qui serait la méthode la
plus juste parce que ça coûterait très
cher 17 sondages surtout
qu'effectivement on n'a pas encore les
listes donc le plus probable c'est une
enquête sur un échantillon le plus large
possible pour faire un rapport de force
global mais en donnant du coup j'en se
prononcer sur étiquette uniquement et
pas sur des candidats on envoie la cedh
et les choix entre terry stellistes et
liste est ensuite de faire des
projections souvent on travaille sur la
base de deux modèles on essaye de tenir
compte quand même de la situation locale
des résultats et peut-être de l'électeur
ce qu'on est en train de faire sur cette
carte électorale etc te ment les
résultats du premier tour devant du
premier du second tour de la
présidentielle regardez ce qui s'est
fait en 2010 c'est donc ces voix là
c'est des projections
mais vous l'avez dit vous-même jeu de
critiquer ce qu'ont fait mes confrères
mais c'est vrai que depuis la prendre
avec des pincettes surtout une deuxième
scénario me parler pour le coup très
hypothétique un bain pour l'instant pour
l'instant si on fait comme si on regarde
que l'alliance entre le rassemblement
national et reconquête on voit pas
comment on pourrait y avoir une alliance
d'appareils à hervé loi ça va être très
compliqué c'est pour ça que je me méfie
beaucoup parce que en fait c'est on est
en présence de configuration tripartite
on a à peu près le même poids un peu
moins à gauche un peu plus côté lrm et
peut-être droite et puis extrême droite
on n'a eu pratiquement la même
configuration à une élection qui était
en 2015 les cantonal et départemental
donc on peut voir ce qui se passe et ce
qui se passe est très intéressant parce
qu'à l'époque c'était à peu près un
tiers chacun c'était un peu moins 7 et
29 % pour l'extrême droite 37% pour la
gauche et puis le reste pour à l'époque
c'était la droite d'un capital et bien
comme il faut 12 5% des inscrits pour se
maintenir la majorité des
circonscriptions seront dans le cas des
cantons c'était des duels mais ça sera
la même chose la même règle pour les y
reconstruire plus on a d'abstention plus
la luz
donc les duels il n'y avait eu
pratiquement 90 % duels et 10% seulement
triangulaire dans ses duels c'est le
parti qui est au centre qui est avantagé
parce que si les duels si vous avez un
duel extrême droite droite la gauche
vient aider la droite si vous avez un
duel droite gauche ou droite france
insoumise l'extrême droite mais vote les
électeurs d'extrême droite viennent
aider la droite et le résultat aux
cantonales a été que avec un peu près
une égalité les trois groupes il ya eu
seulement sur 2000 canton 34 à l'extrême
droite et en a eu sept cents à la gauche
et il y en a eu le reste c'est à dire
plus de 1200 à la droite qui n'étaient
pas qui était plutôt un
tiens un peu plus petit que celui de la
gauche donc on risque d'avoir quelque
chose de très peu démocratique au fond
quelque part le tripartisme c'est
contraire à la démocratie non pour aider
comme la proportionnelle n'est toujours
pas
c'est sûr parce qu'ils on parle quand
même depuis la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy donc on aurait pu sur les 15
dernières années tenté une dose de
proportionnelle à assembler emmanuel
macron a quand même eu l'audace de
remettre ça sur la table alors que là il
est réélu et qu' il est hors de question
de mettre de la proportionnelle en juin
sera pas pour ce scrutin on est bien
d'accord oui moi je me pose deux
questions comme observateur extérieur de
la france la première c'est là le poids
j'allais dire du réflexe politique qui
consiste à donner au président une
majorité est-ce que c'est pas inscrit
dans l'adn politique des français que
une fois qu'on a et lee le locataire de
l'elysée on doit je dis bien on doit lui
donner les moyens de gouverner et ça je
pense que ça va jouer un rôle et la
deuxième chose c'est que dans beaucoup
de cas même si le non cumul des mandats
fait que vous n'êtes plus des buttes
député maire ou sénateur maire les
sortants dans ce type d'élection vont
quand même avoir me semble-t-il une
forte prime ils sont sortants il ils
seront là dans un contexte où je le
rappelle les régionales les sortants ont
été reconduits la présidentielle le
sortant a été reconduit je ne vois pas
pourquoi ce serait différent
législatives alors c'est peut-être ce
mais ce sont des questions et c'est sans
doute ce qu'espère
les députés du parti elle l est
républicain
que restera-t-il des 100 députés aient
l'air à l'assemblée au soir du 19 juin
c'est pour éviter une nouvelle bérézina
électorale que le parti réunissait son
comité stratégique ce matin flora
sauvage et fabien avec nolwenn combat ou
party les républicains alors que le
mauvais score de valérie pécresse à la
présidentielle fait craindre des
défections de personnalités à l'air va
la république en marche un conseil
stratégique s'est tenue ce mardi chez
les républicains interrogé sur une
éventuelle alliance avec le parti macro
nist certains préfèrent garder leur sens
de l'humour si vous êtes bien gentil de
nous demander chaque fois à nous si nous
sommes prêts à mais si c'est pour
disparaître
on a besoin de personne
à l'issue de la réunion alors que
certains ténors du parti favorable à un
rapprochement avec emmanuel macron fuit
les caméras le patron de l air détail la
motion adoptée par le conseil
stratégique y a pas de double
appartenance c'est à dire qu'on est les
républicains on ne peut pas être les
républicains et majorité présidentielle
on ne peut pas être les républicains et
reconquête on ne peut pas être les
républicains et horizons on est les
républicains un groupe indépendant le
patron des députés d'amis un bad ainsi
que l'ancien candidat à la primaire
philippe juvin n'ont pas adopté la
motion mais le parti a l'air tente de
sauver les meubles cette maison n'est
pas à brader au ça ne vous aura pas
échappé donc les républicains ont décidé
de rester un parti indépendant c'est sa
vocation monsieur macron qui espère nous
ramasser à la pelle et la balayette
n'obtiendra pas son objectif le parti
qui n'a obtenu que 88% des voix au
premier tour de la présidentielle
réitère sa position pas d'alliance avec
les métros nist on a l'obligation de ne
pas céder à quelques sirènes qui
pourrait aujourd'hui se faire jour pour
que nous soyons absorbé dans une
majorité n'accroît yann mais au
contraire au nom des français de faire
ce travail d'opposition l air lancera sa
campagne pour les législatives le 7 mai
avec ses traditionnels alliés centristes
et de l'udi adélaïde zulfikarpasic les
électeurs de vallée kress comment
ont-ils voté au second tour de cette
présidentielle alors il était bien
embêté mais néanmoins une majorité
d'entre eux une toute petite m'a même
pas une majorité c'est vraiment un sur
deux à a opté pour un jeu c'est pas si
c'est un réflexe républicain pour faire
barrage ou en tout cas se sont reportées
vers emmanuel macron ils sont néanmoins
un gros tiers plus de +33 % à avoir
choisi de s'abstenir ou de voter blanc
est venu donc pour témoigner d'une
insatisfaction face à cette offre
politique qui ne leur convenait pas et
les 15% restants ont voté pour pour
marine le pen et pour rebondir sur ce
que disait richard vers l'iss qui est
intéressant c'est quand on leur pose la
question aussi de leurs souhaits pour
les législatives pour la suite alors
c'est normal chacun voit un peu midi à
sa porte mais aujourd'hui les électeurs
dans l'absolu et ceux de valérie
pécresse en particulier nous disent
qu'ils ont un souhait de cohabitation va
forcément il souhaite que ce soit leur
majorité c'est pas parce qu'ils ont voté
macron là qui vont pas revenir au
bercail l'arrivée pour leurs députés et
leurs descendants effectivement je
partage tout les annonces qui ont été
faites sur la difficulté de mettre en
oeuvre ce effectivement malgré une
volonté de ne pas vouloir donner signé
un blanc seing pour mayotte macron entre
la participation l'absence de
proportionnelle ma barre pour se
qualifier pour le second tour je pense
que ça aide beaucoup plus complexe que
ça mais en tout cas aujourd'hui les
électeurs français ne sont pas dans une
volonté de se dire comme c'était le cas
en 2010 est ok on a choisi ce président
là on va on va lui donner les moyens de
sa politique là comme c'était un choix
un peu par défaut est contraint enfin
cohabitation c'était un grand moment je
verrais plutôt une colocation enfin
cohabitation
excusez moi mais enfin pourquoi pas les
reee pécresse à mon avis c'est une des
raisons aussi peu de son échec c'est
qu'elle était vraiment très proches me
dire c'est un papier cigarette qui la
sépare des manuels macro et bien sûr
qu'elle a mené une campagne très à
droite racistes etc mais le fondement
politique valérie pécresse n'est pas ça
sont les mêmes racines qu emmanuel
macron même si lui dit qu'il a toujours
cette jambe de gauche qu'on n'a pas
encore vu vraiment mais bon on ne sont
que la cohabitation c'est quand même un
grand mottois oui je pense que si on
refait très vite l'histoire on voit au
premier tour ma croix en fait éclater la
droite c'est l'ancien lycée seulement l
état dont il a été dépossédé en ton
voile à la cartographie de la droite de
pécresse il n'en reste rien des cartes
traditionnelles mais au second tour et
là j'ai été surpris c'est pour ça que
j'ai deux petites cartes
opter au second tour il a été très bien
soutenu par la gauche quand on regarde
j'ai fait j'ai deux cartons dont les
verra peut-être à peine mais qui sont la
carte des gains de macron entre les deux
tours et la carte de la droite des
quatre candidats de la gauche les quatre
candidats de gauche au premier tour les
deux cartes sont pratiquement
équivalente la corrélation entre les
deux c'est 0,9 c d'une chorale s'est
mobilisée
tournoi au second tour elle s'émeut
billard contre marine le pen bien sûr
pour macro qu'on se dit que là mais je
pense que c'est ce ce réflexe là sur
lequel compte macron pour les
législatives ils pensent à propos des
duels que la même chose va se produire
parce que ça c'est très bien produit
j'étais étonné quand j'ai sorti ses deux
carry et puis on revient ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure dans le cas de
figure où on imagine un candidat plutôt
centriste et gonis et puis voilà le rn
enfin et peut-être qu'on n'a pas la
bonne grille de lecture parce qu'on
parte on continue la de raisonner en
termes une droite gauche mais si
emmanuel macron pousse en avant deux
autres curseur est me semble-t-il c'est
ce qu'il va faire l'europe et l'écologie
s'il pousse en avant ça au fond ce qu'il
va chercher une majorité jaillir pour
paraphraser le nom du parti europe
écologie à ce moment-là ça bouleverse
tout parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
candidats actuels ou a déclaré qu'ils
peuvent se retrouver dans une odeur
c'est cohérent sans doute avec ce qui
veut faire de son second mandat me
semblait-il peut l'imaginer en tournée
semble-t-il dont finalement les verts
auront eu au moins un succès c'est que
le monde leur parti europe écologie aura
servi à quelque chose propose une
réaction parce qu'il ya presque autant
de nuances de l air 2 que de leader
chapeau à plumes comme dirait steve
journal dédicace le maire de meaux jean
françois copé alors il milite lui pour
un rapprochement avec la république en
marche en écoute
richard wehrli emmanuel macron c'était
au soir du premier tour qui appelait à
un grand mouvement politique d'unité et
d'action
ça peut pas se résumer à un débauchage
de personnalités
non jusqu'au nom comment ni comme je le
disais je pense qu'il faut il faut que
ça aille au delà de ça alors est ce que
c'est un accord de gouvernement est ce
que c'est à une sorte de programme
commun
pourquoi ne pas employer ce terme
anciens il va falloir qu'ils aillent au
delà pourquoi pas mais un programme
commun justement sur des thématiques par
exemple dit je disais l'europe
l'écologie j'ai plus de peine à voir
emmanuel macron se positionner
radicalement sur l'autorité tel que l'a
décrit à l'instant jean françois copé
parce que copé parce que d'abord
l'autorité c'est quand même un peu
l'échec de son quinquennat passé c'est
le domaine dans lequel sa a flanché à
tous points de vue on a eu les violences
policières ça c'est la très mauvaise
autorités on a eu la dénonciation qui
lui est faite d'autoritarisme notamment
celle et gilet jaune etc donc j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il va emprunter cette
voie merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat j'ai rappelé le
titre les titres de vos livres adélaïde
zulfikarpasic c'est avec anne muxel les
français sur le fil de l'engagement
publié aux éditions de l'aube hervé le
bras il n'y a pas de grands emplacements
c'est votre livre aux éditions grasset
et puis chez richard wehrli cette france
contre elle-même les suit la ligne de
démarcation de 1947 également
chez grasset